it's an incredible number of more than
10 million people have been displaced by
the nine-year long civil war in Syria
which shows no signs of ending as a
result millions of experience with
psychological trauma but may fear
getting help because of a stigma
associated with mental illness in the
region for those who do seek treatment
less than 1% of aid is dedicated to
their mental health we traveled with an
American aid worker to a camp in Jordan
to witness a special program in to
address this crisis in care
this is Market Street here and it's a
wrestling bustling urban centers so does
absolutely you can get pretty much
anything you need that you would find
that online or other cities nearby but
this isn't your average city in the
Middle East it's the center of Commerce
in one of the world's largest refugee
camps the za tree camp in Jordan home to
nearly 80,000 Syrians displaced by civil
war none of us should ever be ok with
calling this normal but it's become an
accepted reality for a lot of people
Mike Nick and Chuck has been doing
humanitarian work here since 2012 this
started as a small collection of tents
but it's turned into something more
permanent I saw that journey of what
started out as shock of adjusting to
this place of leaving home of losing
friends losing family losing the very
sense of identity that was once sacred
that loss would be difficult for anyone
but perhaps hardest for those with
invisible wounds nuclear weapons
chemical weapons barrel bombs we've
innovated in ways to stress people out
to traumatize people and in the same way
we have to innovate by understanding
science and how we can hack those
systems that we already have to heal
Nick and Chuck isn't just an aid worker
he's also a brain scientist
he works for beyond conflict a nonprofit
that combines behavioral science and
humanitarian work to do that here NIC
and Chuck created a self-help tool
called the field guide for barefoot
psychologists through this story about
two displaced Syrians siblings the guide
simplifies brain science and teaches
readers coping skills to recover from
trauma so there are emotional mental
processes that have a physical impact on
your body absolutely it can be addressed
absolutely simple exercises something
very simple using your breath putting
pressure to certain points and joints in
your body activates different aspects of
the nervous system of endocrine system
whatever it might be we believe
knowledge is power
let's give knowledge it's not that hard
phenomena and kapha illusion is a Syrian
refugee living here she leads field
guide sessions to teach mindfulness and
to show others that anger and depression
are natural responses to the horrors
they've experienced
I feel more relaxed but I don't feel as
though I've been through the trauma or
stress that you have of course yes of
course
the body will imply to the brain that I
can relax
maybe Africa feeling me an animal or I
can deal with the situation I'm okay and
we will be able to relax I'm just one
along and at the same time we will be
effective these classes have made all
the difference for Yasmine on the Sun a
mother of four where did you feel the
anxiety where was it
identify it shuts your throat down
nightmares about the war made her seek
out a psychiatrist at saw tree but if
she would give me a medication like
sleeping pills or a sedative I felt like
it was local anesthesia I didn't cook
what after the local anesthesia I go
back to feeling the same way
on the son says which she's learned has
driven much of her anxiety away allowing
her to focus on what really matters
then acidnam not what I want for myself
is to be a good mother to find my way
what I want for my children is to
realize the dreams I had for myself
there's mental health here available to
people how is your program different
anyone is willing to read a story by
using story where functionally doing
group therapy where you're allowing
people who are living in a culture of
incredible stigma against mental health
and affective out where you're still
talking about things by letting people
talk about characters in a story where
they're seeing themselves perhaps the
field guides stories hit home because
they were co-authored by someone who
lived them Muhammad Kier Mustafa what
can you tell me about how you came here
caboose it was a nightmare
she first just going from village to
village then when things got even worse
and the situation became more difficult
there were no options so we had to come
here
Moustafa put his suffering on the page
to improve the lives of his fellow
refugees if a person understood his
surroundings his body his needs if he
understood his responses to
circumstances and traumas then he will
definitely be able to react properly
that certainly would Abdallah Casa juani
hopes for he defected from the Syrian
government and now lives in this sea of
shipping containers but he dreams of
raising his sons in a place with more
opportunities the guide came to help to
open up a person's eyes to help him find
the treasure that lies within him the
guide was able to communicate with a
person's soul this is how the guide was
really able to help the field guide is
currently the subject of one of the
largest studies to measure well-being in
a post-conflict zone and the findings
are promising there's some people who
because of the nature of their PTSD
they're hyper they can't control their
impulses for other people the response
to loss to trauma has been to chill out
to mellow out too much every individual
no matter their symptom profile seems to
be getting what they need if this works
here where else can it work I want to
see this with young incarcerated men in
the United States I want to see
neo-nazis dealing with their own stress
and trauma I want to see migrants coming
across the border dealing with this no
one is guaranteed a life free from
trauma these are universal experiences
these are human experiences that can and
will affect people at all levels of
society and I want to see this in as
many places as possible across the
United States and the fact that so many
people have opened up and volunteered to
utilize the field guide really is a
testament to Mike Nick and Chuck
beyond conflict and even to the
Jordanian government because to some
respect they have essentially said you
know what there is a there's an element
of trust here and we are ready to heal
ourselves I love that last question the
show because it is that how do we use
this elsewhere and even what he didn't
say the idea of people that are doing
gang shootings that are dealing with
loss huge loss in natural disasters
anything like that anything as you said
a universal experience human experience
you